[Music]  are you a snack because I just can't get  enough of you I'm so bloated with love  hey cupcake you look a lot sweeter you  smiled a little it is very important to  dress for the job that you want that's  why I wear because I don't want to then  you have to do actually let you down hey  got it  rabbit by the ball hello a lot of you  have been asking about my makeup routine  so I'm finally gonna share my beauty  secret what you need is one cup of flour  and one stick of butter step one you're  gonna take the flour and start  highlighting all the best parts of your  face so like here and here and I mean  like your whole face is really cute so  basically the whole thing step 2  now we're gonna take the stick of butter  and just like I'm it all over especially  around your mouth and finally for the  most important step to tree beauty and  inner glow  taken  you